[Musica]
siamo veramente sicuri di esserci siamo
realmente consapevoli del fatto che noi
siamo qui e che siamo qui in questo
momento oppure ogni giorno
continuiamo a svolgere le nostre azioni
ormai diventate banali senza porci più
il nostro spirito critico
insomma ci svegliamo andiamo a fare
colazione ci dirigiamo verso la scuola
verso il lavoro che svolgiamo il nostro
compito
poi torniamo a casa per goderci il
nostro meritato riposo non ci accorgiamo
però che tutta questa serie questa
catena di azioni si lega si fa legare ad
una catena inconsapevole che toglie la
nostra testa
la cosa più importante che abbia è la
cosa più potente soprattutto che abbia
il pensiero infatti viviamo in un
sistema purtroppo alla quale siamo
legati sin dalla nascita
insomma noi nasciamo dobbiamo studiare
studiare per trovarci un bel lavoro
trovarci un bel lavoro per garantirci
uno stile di vita adeguato
magari mettere su famiglia come vuol
fare la maggior parte delle persone in
questa società puoi andare in pensione e
goderci anche di un meritato riposo
il nostro destino è fondamentalmente già
scritto
certo abbiamo dei paletti in cui
muoverci non neghiamolo nel senso che
uno può scegliere il suo indirizzo di
studi può scegliere quello che più gli
piace ma fondamentalmente ci muoviamo
entro certi paletti così qual è il
nostro unico obiettivo
quando andiamo a scuola il nostro unico
obiettivo diventa un voto scritto in un
pezzo di carta
noi ci sediamo a scuola ho provato
tramite la mia esperienza senza pensare
che in realtà potremmo dare molto più
alla scuola del semplice studio o di un
semplice voto scritto su un pezzo di
carta potremmo dare la nostra opinione
potremo far sentire la nostra voce
potremo cambiare realmente le cose
ma non lo facciamo perché ci basta un
risultato quando diventiamo più grandi
poi il risultato che vogliamo arrivare
purtroppo è concreto è necessario e
indispensabile
e questi sono i soldi purtroppo al
giorno d'oggi
i soldi vanno oltre ogni cosa mano quasi
oltre l'amicizia mano quasi oltre
l'amore perché oggettivamente senza
soldi non possiamo fare niente non
possiamo mangiare non possiamo viaggiare
non possiamo stare con le persone
fondamentalmente tutto questo che è un
meccanismo inconscio e non ce ne
accorgiamo neanche questo meccanismo fa
sì che quando giriamo al per la strada
vediamo
l'uomo in giacca e cravatta in modo
molto migliore rispetto a come vediamo
l'uomo che chiede l'elemosina accanto a
lui perché diciamo wow
lui è arrivato dove voglia arrivare io
vi è compiuto il rennes piegato bene il
suo tempo mentre invece l'altro
purtroppo per lui poverino lo ha
sprecato ma fondamentalmente chi è che
ci ha detto che l'uomo in giacca e
cravatta sia più felice o abbia più da
dire a noi rispetto all uomo seduto di
fianco chi chiede l'elemosina
un giorno mi sono posto questo dubbio ho
visto un senzatetto che nella via per
andare verso scuola leggeva il mio libro
preferito
allora io ho detto ottima scelta ci
siamo fermati da quella frase a parlare
due ore di qualsiasi cosa abbiamo
parlato di che cosa fosse la libertà di
che cosa valesse il denaro di che cosa
fosse la società di quanto siamo
strettamente legate ad essa senza
poterne mai uscire io penso che dei
discorsi così non avrei potuto farli mai
con nessuno
tutto questo in mai ha scatenato un
meccanismo molto molto più profondo
perché mi ha fatto dire ma se solo una
vicenda del genere ha fatto cambiare in
me l'opinione di qualcosa allora vuol
dire che anche tutto quello che vedo
forse a un oltre c'è qualcos'altro
c'è un più profondo
ero sempre immerso in questa catena
inconsapevole non sapevo come uscirne
allora a queste domande
la risposta è diventato naturale ed è
arrivata attraverso l'unico mezzo che
abbiamo tutti in tutto il mondo in
qualsiasi momento ed è fruibile da tutti
la musica per ma le risposte sono
arrivate attraverso due grandissimi
cantautore
italiani fabrizio de andré e francesco
guccini e andrea mi ha spiegato a
posteriori che non ha senso chiamare il
businessman businessman e il senzatetto
senzatetto o barbone perché realtà siamo
tutti uomini prima di essere questo
siamo tutti uguali tutti nasciamo allo
stesso modo tutti prima o poi moriremo
tutti proviamo gioia amore dolore rabbia
tristezza e questo non fa sì che siamo
tutti uguali
questo fa sì che quello che provo io in
realtà lo provino anche le altre persone
nella sua città vecchia di andrea parla
di prostitute parla di professori e
corrotti parla di politica ma alla fine
dice se non sono gigli son pur sempre
figli vittime di questo mondo
in realtà siamo tutti vittime e viviamo
tutti nella stessa barca per cui da
andrea mi ha fatto dire wow
negli altri posso vedere qualcos'altro
non c'è solo la loro esteriorità non c'è
solo quello che io vedo ma c'è un mondo
dentro come c'è in me e noi lo vediamo
il mondo che c'è dentro di noi
allora c'è anche negli altri francesco
bucci invece dalla parte opposta
mi ha fatto riflettere di più su me
stesso guccini non parla di chissà quali
personaggi emarginati filosofie strane
voce ne parla semplicemente di se stesso
di quello che lui ha vissuto ma sempre
non a chiave poetica e romanzata che ti
fa capire che ogni nostra esperienza
ogni tua esperienza in realtà non è
altro che frutto di qualcosa di molto
più profondo da un'esperienza poi
pensare trarre moltissimi benefici
quindi come dicevo prima non è che tutti
i giorni viviamo e basta
tutti i giorni viviamo e possiamo vivere
ancora più all'interno delle cose questi
due personaggi mi hanno fatto mettere in
dubbio
qualsiasi cosa mi hanno fatto domandare
ma in che direzione sta andando come sto
guardando il mondo e perché lo sto
guardando in questo modo piuttosto che
un altro sono veramente io lo sto
guardando è qualcuno che mi indirizza a
farlo ora
quello che io vi voglio dire non è che
necessariamente voi dobbiate tornare a
casa ascoltare guccini de andrè a
insinuare così nella vostra testa uno
spirito critico
l'unione deve trovare il suo modo ma
quello che vi voglio dire io è che ci
deve essere quel tarlo nella vostra
testa che vi faccia dire ma io dove sto
andando cosa sto facendo perché sono qui
ma io sono qui se dobbiamo accorgere che
l'attimo in cui viviamo è la cosa più
preziosa ed eterna che abbiamo per cui
tornata a casa e mettete in dubbio tutto
mettete in dubbio qualsiasi cosa mettete
in dubbio voi stessi mette in dubbio
vostri genitori mettete in dubbio ma che
vi sto parlando e di te magari non ha
detto una cosa giusta anzi riflettete
mettete in dubbio il senzatetto mettete
in dubbio il businessman del canale
detto che senza tetto abbia per forza
più cose da dire rispetto all uomo in
giacca e cravatta nulla è detto nella
vita
dovete solo sperimentare e provare cosa
sia per voi vivere e cosa possa essere è
solo dal dubbio che può nascere la
libertà di dire io vado dove voglio
andare vado dove mi piace andare sono
chi voglio essere allora la conclusione
che mi viene da dire dopo questa che
nella vita abbiamo un biglietto
questo è per forza di sola andata
sta a noi decidere se quel treno lo
vogliamo guidare noi o far sì che altri
lo guidano per noi
grazie
[Applauso]